now we get into the continuum
when i was a tradet training people
i would start off by giving them a
problem
and then a little bit of space to work
through that problem then another
problem and then a little bit of space
to work
and physical space like okay there's a
problem that's gonna happen before you
get to the target then there's gonna be
a problem on target then there's gonna
be a problem as you leave the target
then there's gonna be a problem as
you're at your extract point
and so they're separated by time and
space so i remember
telling the leadership of this one task
and i said
now i go that did you did a pretty good
job
but what you're going to see happen now
is i am going to compress the time space
continuum that these problems
occur meaning they're going to occur at
the same time in the same location
and that causes problems so the
continuum that we're talking about here
this is no perfect model to use there is
no perfect model to use in explaining
the competition continuum
the many feedback loops it contains make
it very complex so models will omit some
details however the models are useful
because they help explain specific
concepts
and assist marines in building their own
visual age
visualization of the continuum so they
they have this
basically a line on the one on the one
far side is pure peace the other
far side is total war
so it starts with pure peace then it
goes to economic competition
classic diplomacy and geopolitics so
that's sort of like hey we're at peace
but oh
wait we're not quite at peace anymore
now we're moving to economic competition
maybe some classic diplomacy some
geopolitics
and then you get into this area called
political warfare
at the at the far end of economic
competition is political warfare meaning
i'm putting tariffs on you
so now we're getting more aggressive
then you get to this area called the
gray zone which is now
maybe its sanctions and now we're being
really aggressive
then you get to a hybrid war
and then you get to the threat of
violence
and then you get to use of violence
there's a threshold
and once you get past the threshold of
violence you can go further right which
is conventional war
okay we're gonna go to war we're gonna
have your tanks against my tanks and
your airplanes against my plants
and then we get to total war which is
whatever it takes to survive and win
no mercy of any kind
so that's a linear model of this there's
also a circular model that they have and
by the way you can get this
this manual you can just go on the
google
you know one tack four competing and
you'll find it and you can download it
and print it what's up what's
an example of total war and
versus conventional war like which war
was like a total war
the closest i would say we got is world
war ii
to total to total war but we were still
let's face it we were still following
the geneva convention right but imagine
if
things were so bad that you just were
we're just kidding let's just outright
just kill destroy and chemical weapons
and
just total war i mean in in world war ii
you know we drop we dropped the atom
bomb that's
that's freaking straight that's just
total war right you're you're killing
everyone
yeah we firebombed dresden 250 000
civilians
or 250 000 people many civilians dead
an entire city destroyed go google
dresden before and after
i mean it's not quite as shocking as
hiroshima nagasaki before and after but
it's complete and utter devastation it's
as much devastation as we could possibly
cause with the weapons we had at hand
um is there like a scenario where like
one side is that total war
and the other side is like hey we're
going to keep this kind of conventional
i mean it kind of seems like right like
certain we'll say groups whether it be
nations whatever have a certain
philosophy
i would say that yeah i mean i think we
i don't know if we could get to
where someone was at total war i mean i
think the japanese were pretty close i
think the nazis were pretty close
to total war they would do whatever they
you know they'd do whatever
they could but even even um
yeah they even they had limits
yeah you know but i mean let's face it
they were close
they were close i mean japan was doing
their best to develop chemical and
biological weapons that they could use
that they were on that path and would if
they had gotten them you think they
would have done it
i'm gonna say affirmative so they might
have been a total war
you know you can maybe look at some of
these some of these non-state actors
right
i mean isis was isis at total war they
don't have didn't have the capabilities
or the means but if they had
the opportunity to just kill
indiscriminately kill as many people as
they possibly could would they yeah
probably
yeah that's what i mean so like yeah
these groups like yeah they don't have
the
physical capability but that was their
approach like that they in their mind
the next thing was talking about a
circular model a circular model shows
conflict above violence threshold
and competition below it and they kind
of go
through these one of the things that
brings up here one of the actors could
be deterred
so you might think you're going towards
war but then you get deterred
the threat of violence could have been
significant
leverage and other rivals decided you
know what i don't want none of this
tension recedes negotiations of some
kind may have succeeded
bringing the actors back from the
threshold of violence these are all
things that
think about a uh for you as a bouncer
right think about as you approach a
level of
like there's a threshold of violence
where someone's taking a swing think
about all the little things that could
happen that could de-escalate that yeah
you know
maybe it's negotiation hey look man you
just need to get out of here maybe it's
hey we're calling the cops
how often does that one work pretty
often yeah right
yeah that there's a when you whatever
you go through this training
and the that's part of it that whole
thing that escalation of force right and
there's like
many thresholds you know like first it's
like straight up friendly
and the better are we gonna get
roadhouse quotes in here oh yeah
well in roadhouse they do kind of go
over it a little bit
having some like real positive
flashbacks about or images of you
and and and what's his name bodhi
no dalton oh bodies from bodies from
point breaks yeah which i respect by the
way
so yeah well in a way yeah because okay
so dalton that wasn't really a training
that was more of a lecture
and that was a very specific philosophy
which was cool i dig it whatever so
there's different philosophies in the
i would say the continuum of violence
spectrum of the continuum yeah fully but
each yeah each level has
like a little threshold like i said but
yes the most prominent one
is like yeah and it's kind of the same
thing it reflects that total war kind of
situation
where you know like let's go to that end
part of the spectrum right you go
like total war is like we don't have
time for the police to come we gotta
like we gotta act
because this person is violent towards
us or whatever and then it's a
straight-up fight
where you can expect like laws to be
broken
within that fight kind of thing and then
there's like one before where it's like
okay we gotta like put put our hands on
him we gotta whether it be restrain them
or whatever
but we're we're not trying to be violent
towards this person we have to use what
they used to call it the minimum force
necessary
i use that term all the time yeah
minimum force required or minimal force
necessary
yeah i mean i think a more appropriate
term would be you know uh
we'll say an appropriate amount of force
okay you know because
the minimum i don't know there's just a
lot of wiggle room for some some stuff
to not go right
for us you know for the good guys yeah
yeah busted
um you know but that's like the
conventional war kind of scenario
you know and by the way you're telling
the police that the minimum force was
the minimum force required was what was
used yes even though you
may have used the approach appropriately
so there's maybe a little linguistics
jujitsu jiu jitsu happening
yes because we want to you know we don't
want to see echo charles locked up
no back in the day no you don't but i
mean you could it could be argued that
they're the same thing you know where
it's like an appropriate amount of force
meaning like you're not abusing this guy
no matter how much he's verbally
whatever whatever drunk or whatever but
yeah it's
but there is that convince those rules
like yeah put your hands on them use
force
knock them out if you have to you know
you like you can do these kind of things
but you can't be just like violating all
kinds of you know
situations because it's not total war
it's not total war
there's a line in here it says there are
many possibilities on how
rivals can turn away from the violence
threshold
and return to steady-state competition
and i made a note here for myself
that crossing that line
is almost always
a tactical move a tactical meaning
it is an immediate it's solving this
immediate problem but it is
seldom a strategic move because think
about it when
if you're in the street and you get into
a fight you want to do everything you
can to avoid that fight
and if you have to engage in that fight
it's almost guaranteed to be a tactical
win
and a strategic loss now you got to go
to jail now you got to pay this guy
money now you got to get arrested now
you got cuts on your hands
you got all these little problems and it
would have been
infinitely better to have just said you
know what this guy's not worth it or
whatever you walk away
from a leadership perspective it is
almost always almost always
if you cross if you cross the line and
there's some
gap but indirect when you go from from
indirect
influence to direct it's
almost always attack it might be
attacked to win it's going to be a
strategic loss so the minute i say you
know what dave i'm not talking about
this anymore here's what you're going to
do
that's almost guaranteed to be a
tactical win because you're going to go
and execute whatever i told you to do
but guess what strategically i just took
a step back i took a strategic hit i'm
not saying i can't recover from it
but strategically it's a negative so we
have to be careful of that